hello I'm are Shanker from the Yale
Physics Department and I'm here to
discuss this book written by my
colleague Doug stone so Doug what makes
this interesting for me is that first of
all you've written a book and the book
is about quantum mechanics and that's
really how we met many many years back
when I was a struggling postdoc at
Harvard and I was teaching the summer
school and I was teaching quantum
mechanics refridgerated writing a book
and you're one of the four students who
never gave me a minute's peace during
those lectures but you obviously have
mastered the subject well enough to
write this book so first question is
what took you so long
well the what took me so long is that
you did the easy thing right so you
taught me quantum for the first time is
this mind blowing subject where you have
to throw out everything you know about
physics and billiard balls and suddenly
things are tunneling through walls and
so on I won't repeat the dirty joke you
made at the time and so as soon as you
learn this subject you say okay I want
to go teach somebody which is exactly
what you did right so you wrote the
classic textbook which is a best-seller
now in in physics on this and and you
kind of taught the subject to physicists
and I didn't see where the market was
for me to just try to do what you had
done particularly since I helped you so
you know so much with writing it
certainly that's true in my dedication I
mentioned my debt to you for making me
think so hard about the book and you
were always relentless in pursuing
everything right
so that was a great example but you know
me coming from my social science
background in philosophy background I
would write something not for physicists
but for the general audience it might be
also interesting to physicists but
certainly something you could read with
very few equations and so I didn't know
how to do that what would be interesting
and then through some serendipity I
discovered that there was this big
understanding among both the general
public and physicists about Einstein's
role Einstein the most famous scientist
in history well that looks a little bad
topic because when I tried to write my
quantum book they said we already have
one thank you in fact we already have 20
there probably 500 books on Einstein so
you got to justify your chopping down
all the streets to write your book
what's your reason well so so it turns
out that there are a thousand books
written on relativity and there are
another 200 biographies which slice and
dice him at all angles
but since quantum is such a challenging
subject and since Einstein at the end of
his life said that he didn't like the
theory he wasn't going to use it the
people have never written a book which
just ignores essentially relativity and
instead focuses on his contributions to
this other theory the theory of atoms
and of stuff in the world and it turns
out when you strip away all the sort of
distraction of his brilliant work in
relativity but very distracting then you
see wow he's actually the father of
quantum too
yeah I think I was surprised as you said
I've thought about teaching quantum
mechanics a lot and you don't see
Einstein's name that much even in the
textbooks there's something about the
photoelectric effect and that's about
the end it's all about Max Planck and
everybody else but when I read your book
I realized that even though Max Planck
is the father of quantum mechanics he
kind of disowned his own baby fairly
soon and Einstein is the one who
fearlessly took up the notion of the
quantum of quantized energy and
quantized action and ran with it when
most of his senior colleagues were
skeptical that's the part that's
certainly not well known yeah well since
it took 26 years to do go from Planck's
first idea in 1900 which is how I start
the book all the way to Schrodinger and
Heisenberg in 1925 26
many of the people that were there when
the final solution arose didn't know
what happened in the first decade or so
when Einstein was the only loan you know
crier in the wilderness saying things
are really going to have to change
there's gonna have to be a totally new
theory and that's really what what
captivated me that the story of Planck
as I begin the book is more a story of
damage control because his reputation is
in danger then it is one of trying to
find a new set of laws of physics and
was really Einstein five years later and
then for the subsequent five years who
mostly worked on that and said there is
going to have to be a new law of nature
forever I think there are two
interesting things I learned from the
book number one the people we associate
with quantum mechanics really would not
behind Einsteins in the support of
quantum mechanics even though some of
them were the inventors of it and a
question is what gave him the conviction
that this was the right path and also
maybe it'll be helpful if he spell out
what all he did for quantum mechanics in
other words what are the three or four
things that are the heart of quantum
mechanics and you got to tell me where
Einstein fingerprints are in the birth
of those ideas yes well of course you
know this is is really what the book is
about so I'll have to just kind of throw
out a few tidbits hopefully that will
will stimulate people to actually look
at the book but the first one is this
idea that energy can't change
continuously you know if I if I have a
pendulum and it's swinging back and
forth and it has some energy in it
I can just move the pendulum a little
higher and it'll go fast you know back
and forth faster sorry with more energy
and I can do that continuously but with
an atom if I try to change the energy of
an electron you can't do that
continuously and this is often
attributed to Planck but it's actually
really something that flows from
Einsteins work and Planck essentially
tried to run away from this implication
of his own work so just there at the
beginning of quantum when the word
quanta or quantization came in
Einstein really was the one that gets a
lot of credit then he was the one that
realized that after 50 years or 60 years
of thinking of electromagnetic waves
light and the other kinds
electromagnetic waves as just being away
phenomenon he suddenly said no no
actually maybe they could be particles
too and now we do think of light that
way as being made up of both of
particles called photons although they
have wave-like properties after
interrupted for a second it is true that
wave particle duality is at the heart of
quantum mechanics I have never heard it
associated with Einstein in any kind of
textbook I felt like reading whereas in
your book there are actual words written
by Einstein where he says explicitly
that imagines a time when you will have
to describe particles and waves at the
same time but he wanted to talk about
electron yeah so that quote from 1909
which is 14 years before de Broglie
who's now usually the one you always
mention in this regard was extraordinary
and I even have quotes from people in
the audience saying you know Planck
immediately got up and squashed it and
just said no he didn't quite agree with
it and Planck was so much more eminent
that it just didn't get anywhere so this
this pillar of quantum theory which we
associate with a much later era and
other names is actually really due to
Einstein and now one of the very
little-known things that I go on to talk
about a little bit in my book is that
when you have this problem that isn't a
wave or is it a particle the way we
resolve that today is by saying well the
wave is a wave of probability and this
is always associated as an idea of Max
Born Einsteins close friend but in fact
it turns out in stein have been saying
this for about four years or five years
before born came up with the idea and he
just took it from Einstein's application
to light and applied it to electrons and
then he wrote Einstein saying see look
how well your idea is doing with
electrons with Schrodinger wave so it's
interesting that the part of art
mechanics Einstein is supposed to have
hated namely the probabilistic notion
right is the one that he brought up for
the first
and it's it's kind of crazy because he
just threw it out there he you know was
almost like a throwaway yes if you can't
really figure out the final theory then
this is a stopgap measure and of course
you could do this but he was the first
one to do it you know I mean and it's
not clear that Bourne and these other
people would have thought of that if
they didn't know it from Einstein's
informal reasoning which was never
published but which we know about
through other people's letters he's
talking about letters you mentioned a
very interesting letter he got from the
Indian comet which would be very
interesting story to read even if you
did not care anything about science just
to see how ethical behavior should be
like and how people trustingly write to
experts asking for their support and
sometimes they get it sometimes they get
Scoob and so tell me a little more oh
yes yes thank you so the Indian comet as
you know is is the term I used for
sachindra nath bose who was a brilliant
young physicist but unknown to the world
in india around the early 1920s his
career was beginning and he was trying
from a great distance to make sense of
quantum theory as it was evolving and he
had an idea of how to move it forward
beyond some some intermediate notions of
classical physics he sent this paper to
Einstein and if you read this in a
Hollywood script you'd say come on this
is ridiculous you know
Einstein's the most famous scientist in
the world one of the most famous people
in the world he doesn't know this guy he
doesn't read English very well this
thing comes in English the guy asked him
to translate it for M who's who asked
iDEN Stein to translate their paper yeah
and so but somehow Einstein reads it
fights his way through the English and
we decides it's right and then goes on
and promotes this idea and really
extends it and understands it more
deeply than Bose and now because
Einstein always spoke about it as boses
idea half of the fundamental particles
and physics are called bosons after such
endrin FL
mm-hmm and the Nobel Prize was given
only after year 2004 actually confirming
the phenomenon of Bo's condensation or
bose-einstein condensation maybe you
want to say a little bit about what that
is that's another popular idea well
there is something that got into the the
public eye because it was sort of a holy
grail for physicists which was to show
that if you cooled things down low to
low enough temperature which even though
it really feels very very cold today
outside we're not quite at the you know
ten to the minus nine degrees above
absolute zero that it actually took but
but if you get there you can make all
the atoms behave exactly identically
fall into the same quantum state and
they then flow without any friction and
in condensed matter as you know this
leads to super conductivity which is
actually a important phenomenon
technologically and magnets for MRI and
things like that but Einstein was the
source of all of that Bose himself never
understood this condensation phenomenon
also coming to the end in this later
beers he would pour Dogg's key and Rosen
wrote this very important paper where he
told the world why he cannot accept
quantum mechanics but in doing so he
spelled out what is really true about
quantum mechanics nobody has changed
their mind on how bizarre quantum
mechanics is all he was saying is that
he couldn't accept it but he had put his
finger on the craziest part of quantum
theory so yeah that's a that's that's a
great place to conclude let me just say
two things about that
so first the question is what is it that
led him to reject this theory which is
now so successful that it underlies all
our modern technology of computers
lasers communication chemical processes
it's it's it's fundamental to to the
technology of the 20th and 21st century
and it was already beginning to be so
when he was rejecting it so the reason
he rejects it as I argue in my book is
that in quantum theory as you taught me
there is this reference to the observer
and things change
in the physical universe when an
observation is made but Einstein
believed that he was discovering eternal
truths about nature that didn't rely on
having any humans in the universe at all
and he felt that this standard view of
quantum theory undermined the whole
philosophical reason that he did physics
and the thousands of worlds outside they
had and our job is to describe it and
not to be part of it exactly
and he kept saying that to the very end
he used to say it very briefly with the
phrase do you really believe the moon
isn't there when you don't look at it
but his last gift to quantum theory that
you alluded to was to actually tease out
the craziest thing in it which is that -
distant particles can be somehow
affecting one another in what's called
entanglement
he called it spooky action at a distance
and and that to him meant that it
couldn't really be describing reality
because nothing can travel over
distances instantaneously and now we
know that that implication of his is
actually completely correct he was
hoping it was a disproof but it wasn't
and it now underlies this modern 21st
century not yet realized technology of
quantum computing that's we're so
involved in at Yale that it's kind of
ironic that though as I go back to my
lab I'll be looking at people working on
this entanglement at a distance so okay
well that's very nice so I want to
conclude by asking you to confirm or
deny a rumor that this book of yours is
going to be made into a movie and I'm
being seriously considered Lee the
fourth honor of the electron oh I
thought you were going to be the Indian
comet okay but I think there's one thing
I think our any experience is showing I
don't think we've actually said the
title of the book at any point in this
discussion why don't you read it out
okay
Einstein in the quantum the quest of the
valiant Swabian you will you will be
fine yeah coming to a theater near you
right after Indiana Jones and the Temple
of Doom thank you very much